clean to me this when we were younger my
sister and I we didn't have a family car
in the Philippines we had an unmarked
taxi mm-hmm that drove us with with when
we had a driver named us money cysts are
okay and it was an unmarked taxi that
didn't have a meter and and we'd that
was our car for like eight years you had
a driver I know but why did my dad
insist on making look like a taxi so you
wanna be pretentious yeah I just wanna
look like you guys are a rich white girl
but you were yeah it's so strange people
are eating beetles outside you had an
unmarked tax-free rides everywhere he
refused to have just a regular that
reminds me of a story I don't know why
but it's a little dark but when I was a
kid my mom picked me up from camp and um
all the kids got out for the bus this
bus and they go to their moms and they
hugged their moms you know cuz we've
been gone for two weeks or whatever and
I remember and poaching my mom's she
came to hug me and I pushed her why what
were you I don't remember like eight
maybe nine mom something and I remember
like we're in the car and my mom
backhanded me 40 [ __ ] time good the
Asian style but no like a hard hits good
oh no I think you're yeah I carry you
back good PAP deserve tap and for like
gays I just never left the room I was
like it was summertime and I was just
just crying and trembling good I don't
know why I did that though yeah your
little [ __ ] yeah I think we've all done
stuff like that I've called my mom I
don't know why she she gave me the wrong
when I was like seven she gave me the
wrong hamburger I asked for a Wendy's
junior bacon cheeseburger she gave me
one without bacon and she ate it took a
bite I saw and I said you're such a fat
so high like that she looked at me say
[ __ ] did you say yeah she dragged my arm
into a dark room I don't know why yeah
pinched me tell the [ __ ] nails touch
here's my cheat I love it I love don't
call your mama fat so yeah at least you
guys got hit because you deserved it
yeah you got hit for fun for sport no my
mom is going through some things you
know but let me tell you something I
don't think that I don't hit my dog I
don't ever hit people in general but if
I had a 16 year old daughter who came
home and said [ __ ] you you stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] knockout oh my god I will grab
that I was snatch her by the by the
[ __ ] hair and I will drag her through
the neighborhood and shame her like
Circe's there say so what do you guys
think about parenting your kids gonna do
we want to do that kind of punishment
but when you okay I'm gonna I like this
scenario okay but I wanted to tell you
what a 16 like I was that 16 year old
okay he'll be coming so this is what if
I was a girl right and you grabbed my
hair yeah this is what I would do
so you grab my hair we'll say it to me
first get angry hey mom you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh yeah I'll say it okay then you hit me
right you know what I would do as that
rebellious 16 year old all right I
parked my [ __ ] no no I wouldn't just hit
you I wouldn't even let you go I
wouldn't I clinch you to Rich Franklin
yeah yeah all right okay after that
beating yeah what I was doing all right
you know
Touche and then I buddy I would go to my
room yeah pack my stuff yeah and never
see you again
no you wouldn't I think seniors are
scared because I as a CTO if you and I
had a kid yeah I think our six-year-old
be kind of cute so I'll be like you know
what I'm gonna use my [ __ ] if we went
take advantage some [ __ ] no I think that
that's what that me use my [ __ ] to get
some [ __ ] my dad is Bobby Lee
oh my god parenting is tough mental I
feel like you're gonna be the end of me
one way or the other you know yeah you
guys will do good cop bad cop right or
both that's sure good cop for sure crazy
let's go to Barney's and me and my
daughter at Barney's shopping come
what's a clinch you two yeah we'll both
have black eyes my daughter and I are
walking around with bloody faces with a
lot of merch one thing I require out of
a father and a husband what is that you
have to and I will do give show you the
same respect you have to co-sign with my
decisions and we have to stand firm
together it's like that's why I'm right
now I mean it I know this that were if
you we had kids you and I the whole
family would be under your leash why
does that be I think we would all begin
like tiptoeing around you know man like
a horse yeah yeah you know because we're
so scared of making the wrong move
you'll be powerful I don't need to be
friends with my children while I raise
them we can be friends later down the
road
you'll get it they'll respect you
wouldn't be from either my side I will
treat you like my child give me an
example I want to give you an example of
okay so Gilbert's our kid yeah okay so
what would he something he'd be do let's
see he I got in a fight at school
no he's got you know he got we got a
call from his school saying that they
found weed in his backpack no weed all
right and he's kicked out of school for
a week okay what I would do yeah I mean
if you're going to do that let's don't
bring it to school I not I don't
disagree with you experimenting with
drugs oh sweet but I think that we can
probably do that in a way where you
don't get in trouble with school and
other Authority like authority figures
so let's do it in a more controlled
setting I'm not against it but let's do
it the right way let's be some
about it are you responsible about your
weed smoking cuz the society hasn't
caught up to marijuana use yet so in the
meantime let's just be smart about where
we bring it in where we smoke it smoke
it here yeah every day he's 16 by the
time I have a seat I want a loss would
have been change I'm gonna say that
listen listen what's your name Gabriel
Gabriel yeah Gabriel yeah number one
you're 16 mm-hmm I in my house I just
want you to follow the law not the law
of my house the law of the country all
right so I don't want you to be drinking
in my house you're not 21
all right I want I don't want you to be
smoking weed in my house you're not 18
or whatever how old you need to be to
get it right then what the medical
marijuana you have to be 18 right Yeah
right so you're just gonna follow the
rules of the law what if I don't wanna
if don't then I you're gonna be cut off
from me all right and you're gonna make
me an enemy and I'm gonna make your
heart life very difficult
I'm sorry papa okay then you're more
than disciplinarian then do a ssin I
mean no but I'm not being a discipline
there I'm just saying you are I don't
want a legal [ __ ] going on my house
don't kill anybody don't rape anybody
else you know kids are going to do it
anyway so it's like at least let him
know okay you're gonna do it whether I
say not to whether I allow it or don't
right you're gonna do it so at least
let's hatch a plan to where you don't
get caught for your [ __ ] see now you're
a bad parent be responsible don't be a
[ __ ] I'm gonna stop again then stop
again Lee yeah okay look at me son yeah
Gabriel you also know that alcoholism
and drug addiction runs through our
family we'll talk about that no look
look it runs through our family
your uncle Steve hasn't okay I have it
my your grandfather has it alcoholism
all right so as long as
living in this house you're not gonna
drink or do drugs or anything at 18 when
you leave you can do whatever you want
okay but not in my house okay that's it
okay he's gonna do it anyways I don't
know okay and then you're gonna and then
he's gonna bring out my dad and me and
he's gonna get beat by a golf club I
don't want that I just let the dead but
maybe you are more of a disciplinarian
than me I think maybe I am actually was
that Ariel it was like flipped if I
thought it would I don't suffer from an
addiction I've always had you know
relatives like relatively good control
of like what I experimented with and I'm
sort of a square anyway so I don't I
don't know the fear of spiraling out of
control like you so you probably fear
that for your own son whereas I don't
necessarily mmm because I never
experienced it so I get where you're
coming from yeah I mean the thing is
that I'm just scared of the the disease
part of it you know because I just feel
like it's in genetic my genetics right
so um I you know when a kid is born to
an alcoholic family from well I mean
their parents an alcoholic they still
might have the gene and so inevitably
they will just become an alcoholic I
don't think it's avoidable but I still
want my kid to know that even if it is
and if you if you are in your an
addiction that there is a way out like I
have friends in a that their dads and
moms have 50 years of sobriety in a a so
they you know they would do their drugs
and stuff but inevitably they knew how
to reach out and get sober
oh I have a really good question about
that so when you have a child and you
let's say for instance someone like you
you're very well aware of your addiction
do you share that early on with your
child or does it become you have a fear
that it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy for him where it's like well my
parents are addicts so yes I have a
higher propensity so they resigned to
the idea of addiction versus never
telling them and perhaps there is no
self-fulfilling prophecy where they
don't they don't automatically if life
is going bad you're like well it's in my
genetics anyway
cuz you know how teenagers are so full
of [ __ ] they're still hormonal they
don't necessarily like think they think
that I'm just predisposed to it so yeah
I am a [ __ ] you know you you bring
your kids to meetings you do yeah early
on scared-straight show them no no you
just know if I had a kid and I was like
hey dad let's go have lunch yeah okay
but you have to go to this meeting with
me so we sit in the a meeting right for
one hour I'll take you to wherever you
want to eat lunch if you want to go get
ice cream we can get ice cream then we
go home
my point is is that you do it like as if
you know you're set you tell them about
the disease you say your father has a
sickness and it's called alcoholism I
know I haven't done drink haven't drank
or done drugs in a very long time but I
have to maintain my recovery would you
be open about telling him all your
monster stories well I mean not lying
choosers yeah pick and choose I mean I
don't know how old that person the kid
is but you know I just think that you
just have to be honest you know but yeah
I think I would be the discipline then
yeah but not in terms of grades and
stuff I don't care about grades I don't
know if I care about grades so much as I
they can show me that they're learning
things and they're showing some type of
like real like effort and discipline
discipline is a big thing work ethic is
a big thing for me if you have to have
it you have to kind of instill that very
early on you can't just get by doing
nothing Bobby you can yeah I know I know
but the thing is is this is that you
should like when Deepak Chopra raised
his kids he said that he didn't tell
them to go to Princeton and [ __ ]
Harvard he didn't care you don't say you
have to get straight A's no he said help
other people yeah you know and become a
good person I think I think that's very
important because look what happened to
Chosun we Virginia jack dick that kid
you know very good grades yeah
their parents owned a laundromat I
believe yeah he had a sister that went
to NYU or something and he cracked no he
he got good grades but he didn't have
any friends if my kid doesn't didn't
have any
friends at all viewers and had no social
life yeah at all and would talk to
things that aren't there
I'm more concerned about that yeah
that's my biggest fear is like when that
kid from Santa Barbara kid that shot up
Santa Barbara what's his name
Elliott Elliott Rogers you know his dad
was white
his mom was Asian his dad's a director
yeah mom is I think know as that is
right and a real director and now you
can see photos of the mom and dad when
they first find out about all those kids
yeah and the photo of the mom there's a
photo of them his Asian mom and her eyes
are like red and teary and there's a
sense of severe shock and horror you can
see it online I don't ever want to have
that face yeah because that right there
it's it's over
whatever my life you know is or was it's
all gonna be based on that moment that's
also my biggest fear and I've actually
talked to my my doctor about this in
terms of procreation I don't I'm so
afraid of raising a child with any type
of like severe mental illness because I
I don't know like I just think that
would be so difficult you know something
like maybe I can probably tackle
depression and anxiety and talk immuno
through those stages but when it comes
to real hardcore stuff like
schizophrenia schizophrenia and your
family I don't have any media but we
have a lot of like you have addiction I
have I have mental illness like
depression and anxiety yeah but we don't
have like the severe ones in your family
no but depression is pretty bad soon
sometimes a I don't know I I fear that
maybe our Cross is going to also
alcoholism though isn't a bad thing I I
believe that my brother and I I can't
speak for my brother I know he feels
this way
I'm glad that we have the disease
because it taught me how to live a
better life
without me having the disease I wouldn't
know the things that I know the tools
like living in the moment and wanting to
be a better person whatever so it's like
if I was just a regular guy I just
wouldn't have the tools that I didn't
have now and I'm glad I have those tools
and so I don't think that it's a if I
had a kid with alcoholism or drug
addiction my only prayer would be so
that they would you know have a
spiritual awakening you know and get why
they need to get sober but once they're
in the like 12-step stages I would just
be delighted I think you know but no muy
Thai clinches then don't more tell muy
Thai clinch
[Music]